In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen!
The reading from the Sinaxadion for September 21st, on which we commemorate, the leave-taking
of the exaltation of the precious and life-giving cross, and the Holy Apostle, Quadratus.
On the 21st of the month, we celebrate the leave-taking of the exaltation of the Holy
Cross and the memory of the Holy Apostle, Quadratus, at Magnesia.
Quadratus was a wise and learned man who lived at the time of our Savior, whose disciple
he became.
Full of the Holy Spirit, he was consecrated bishop of Athens, where he brought to the faith
many pagans who could find no answer in their proud sophistries to his God-bearing words.
Christ's enemies were jealous at his success and stoned him and tormented him in many ways
before driving him from his sea.
He made his way to the city of Magnesia, and there also his aluminum-teaching worked
miracles in driving away the darkness of idolatry.
He received the crown of martyrdom in the reign of Hadrian in the years 117 through 138.
His body, which was venerated at Magnesia, brought healing and consolation to all who approached
it with faith.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord Jesus Christ, our God, have mercy on us
and save us.